I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hi, friend. Good morning, friend. Today we're talking about The Secret. We kind of have a big day today, you guys. We have some fun stuff. We have family coming in town, both of us. So I think we're feeling all of that. But we're excited to
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。嗨，朋友。早安，朋友。今天我们讨论的是“秘密”。各位，今天对我们来说是个相当重要的日子。我们有一些有趣的事情。我们两人的家人都要来镇上。所以我想我们都能感受到这一切。但我们很高兴能
talk to you about The Secret. Season 2, Episode 13, written by Lee Eisenberg and Jean Stupnitsky, directed by Denny Gordon. Let's talk a second about Denny Gordon. Denny Gordon is my first fast fact. Let's do it. You hit me with a fast fact and then I'll add a little color to it. Fast fact number one, directed by Denny Gordon. Denny is a woman. D-E-N-N-I-E, Gordon. She would go on to direct Boys and Girls. She's also directed several episodes of John Krasinski's show Jack Ryan for Amazon. She does a lot of dramas. Yeah. Denny was fantastic. She was just a wonderful, delightful person to be around. I have a great photo of all of
和你聊聊“秘密”。第二季第13集，由李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼茨基编剧，丹尼·戈登执导。我们花点时间聊聊丹尼·戈登。丹尼·戈登是我的第一个快讯。我们开始吧。你抛出一个快讯，然后我会为它增添一点色彩。快讯一，由丹尼·戈登执导。丹尼是一位女性。D-E-N-N-I-E，戈登。她后来执导了《男孩与女孩》。她还为亚马逊执导了约翰·卡拉辛斯基的剧集《杰克·莱恩》的几集。她拍了很多剧情片。是的。丹尼棒极了。她是一个相处起来非常棒、令人愉快的人。我有一张很好的照片，是
us. All of us gals gathered around her. We were excited to have another female director. Yeah. We gathered around her and we have a great picture with her. I often did this though. It wasn't gender-specific, you guys. I have photos with us with all the directors. Yes, you would take photos with the male directors as well. I did not discriminate. I did not discriminate. I have a great picture of me with Harold Ramis. But Denny was just such a delight and I wanted a photo with her. We actually had only six female directors through the nine years of the office. And they were Mindy Kaling, Jen Salata, Amy Heckerling,
我们所有人。我们所有的姑娘都围在她身边。我们很高兴能有一位女性导演。是的。我们围在她身边，和她拍了一张很棒的照片。不过我经常这样做。各位，这不分性别。我和所有导演都有合影。是的，你也会和男导演合影。我没有歧视。我一视同仁。我和哈罗德·雷米斯有一张很棒的合影。但丹尼实在太招人喜欢了，我很想和她合影。在《办公室》的九年里，我们实际上只有六位女性导演。她们是曼迪·卡灵、詹·萨拉塔、艾米·海克林、
Claire Scanlon, Kelly Cantley, and Denny Gordon. So ladies out there directing. We love you. Keep doing it. Yeah. Let's get some more ladies directing. That's my little speech there. I love it. Denny was and is a trailblazer in terms of female directors. She's been around a really long time and when researching this episode, I ended up reading a bunch of articles and interviews with her about her experience. Her journey. Yeah, I did too. And it was very inspiring. So guys, Google her. Yeah. D-E-N-N-I-E Gordon. Denny, if you hear this, we're sending you some love. All right. Where are we at, Jenna? Fast fact number two. We've got a
克莱尔·斯坎伦、凯利·坎特利和丹尼·戈登。所以，正在进行导演工作的女士们。我们爱你们。坚持下去。是的。让我们有更多女性导演吧。这是我的小演讲。我太喜欢了。丹尼过去是、现在也是女性导演领域的先锋。她在这个行业已经很久了，在研究这一集时，我最终读了很多关于她经历的文章和采访。她的心路历程。是的，我也是。这非常鼓舞人心。所以大家去谷歌搜索她吧。是的。D-E-N-N-I-E 戈登。丹尼，如果你听到这个，我们向你表达爱意。好了。我们到哪儿了，珍娜？快讯二。我们有一个
big guest star. We're going to introduce a new recurring character, Tom Chick, who plays Gil. Yes. Oscar's boyfriend. Oscar's love interest. It's a secret. He appeared in four episodes as Oscar's boyfriend, Gil. He also had a recurring role as a reporter on the West Wing. So you might recognize him from that. But here's the crazy thing about him. His big passion in life is video gaming. Okay. And he is a very famous video gaming writer. He's written tons of articles, tons of blogs. He's like a video gaming critic. This is amazing. Fascinating. This is just proves, guys. I always say this. You don't know me. You don't know someone. You have
大牌客串明星。我们要引入一个全新的常驻角色，饰演吉尔的汤姆·奇克。是的。奥斯卡的男友。奥斯卡的意中人。这是个秘密。他作为奥斯卡的男友吉尔出演了四集。他还在《白宫风云》中常驻出演过记者。所以你可能从那里认出他。但关于他最疯狂的事情是。他生活中的最大热情是电子游戏。好吧。他是一位非常著名的电子游戏作家。他写过无数的文章、无数的博客。他就像一个电子游戏评论家。这太棒了。太迷人了。各位，这证明了一件事。我总是这么说。你不了解我。你不了解某人。你根本
no idea how layered and complex people are. I had no idea. Yeah. Wow. That's cool. All right. Are we ready for fast fact number three? Yes. Steve Carell was nominated for a Golden Globe for playing Michael Scott. This was his first nomination for playing Michael Scott the week we shot this episode. And then he won the Golden Globe the week this episode aired. Yes. This was a huge upset shocker win. First of all, the fact that he was nominated was insane because he was nominated for those six episodes from season one. You have to remember, we were barely on the air. We were gonna get canceled at any minute and we didn't
不知道人们是多么有层次、多么复杂。我完全不知道。是的。哇。太酷了。好了。我们准备好听快讯三了吗？是的。史蒂夫·卡瑞尔因饰演迈克尔·斯科特而获得金球奖提名。这是他在我们拍摄这一周因饰演迈克尔·斯科特获得的首个提名。然后在这集播出的那一周，他赢得了金球奖。是的。这是一场爆冷获胜。首先，他被提名的事实太疯狂了，因为他是凭第一季的那六集获得提名的。你必须记住，我们的节目当时几乎没什么收视率。我们随时都可能被砍掉，而且我们在业内也
have a lot of clout around town. No. Not at all. So this was like an upset and we were thrilled. It couldn't happen to a nicer person. Steve's acceptance speech is amazing. You can go on YouTube and type in Steve Carell's Golden Globes acceptance speech for 2006. He gets up there and he's like, I didn't really know what to say. So my wife Nancy wrote my speech. It's one of the best speeches ever. It's so great. And then the whole thank you is from Nancy's perspective. Yes. And it's really funny. Steve was invited to go to the actual ceremony, but the cast, we were invited to a viewing party that was held on a roof of a building. It was
没什么影响力。没有。一点也没有。所以这就像是一个大冷门，我们激动万分。这再适合不过一个如此善良的人了。史蒂夫的获奖感言太精彩了。你可以上YouTube搜索2006年史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的金球奖获奖感言。他走上台说，我真的不知道该说些什么。所以我的妻子南希帮我写了发言稿。这是史上最棒的演讲之一。太棒了。然后整个致谢都是从南希的角度出发的。是的。真的非常有趣。史蒂夫被邀请参加当天的正式颁奖典礼，但我们演员阵容被邀请去参加一个在建筑屋顶举行的观看派对。那
it's actually a parking garage. Okay. And it's like the roof of the parking garage, but they tint it and we're basically across from the hotel where the globes are where the globes are happening. We're sort of like, if you self-parked to stay at this hotel. Yeah. We were in the self-park garage building. We are now the only actors on top of a parking garage in a fancy tent with a bunch of people that look like bankers. Yeah. Who are very quiet as they watch the show. We are now the rowdy crowd in the corner. Yeah. And Steve's category comes on. They announce him, you know, when they announced his nomination, we're
其实是一个停车场。好吧。就像是停车场的屋顶，但他们搭了帐篷，我们基本上就在举办金球奖的那个酒店对面。我们有点像那种，如果你自己开车去这家酒店停车的话。是的。我们就呆在自助停车场大楼里。我们现在是唯一一帮站在停车场楼顶、呆在豪华帐篷里的人，周围还有一群看起来像银行职员的人。是的。他们在看节目时非常安静。我们现在是角落里吵闹的一群人。是的。然后史蒂夫的奖项类别开始了。他们宣布他，你知道的，当他们宣布他的提名时，我们
like, whoa, yeah, Steve. Go Steve. Go Steve. That already raised eyebrows. We're already like, whoa, Steve. People are already like, when are they doing? So then y'all, he won. Wait, can we reenact what you and I did when they said, and the winner is Steve Carell. Ready? Okay. And the winner is Steve Carell. Tackle people. Hug people. Tackle. Have you seen, like, when a team wins the World Series? It's a bad news bearers moment. And they haven't won in like 50 years. That is what the cast of the office looked like. We were tackling one another. In our fancy dresses. In our fancy dresses. Running around, whooping it up. I
就像，哇，太棒了，史蒂夫。加油史蒂夫。加油史蒂夫。这已经让人侧目了。我们当时就想，哇，史蒂夫。人们已经在想，他们在干什么？然后呢，各位，他赢了。等等，我们可以重现一下当他们宣布“获胜者是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔”时你和我做了什么吗？准备好了吗？好的。“获胜者是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔”。扑倒别人。拥抱别人。扑倒。你见过那种球队赢得世界大赛的情况吗？这是一个“少壮派”的时刻。而且他们已经有50年没赢过了。这就是《办公室》演员们的反应。我们互相扑倒对方。穿着华丽的礼服。穿着华丽的礼服。跑来跑去，大喊大叫。
mean, we were insane. Now we have to wait for the whole rest of the show to be over. And finally. But we're in full party mode. We're partying it up. I mean, we're having a blast. We're waiting for Steve to come to the party. Yeah. So here's the thing. When the show ends, everyone, I guess that's inside where it's being filmed, they file out and they actually come into the tent where we are. Yeah. And I don't even think we knew that. You're like, oh my god. And Steve walked in holding his award. And we tackled him. And then we started posing for group photos with the Golden Globe and Steve. The looks on our faces, we
我的意思是，我们当时太疯狂了。现在我们得等整个节目的其余部分结束。最后。但我们完全进入了派对模式。我们在疯狂庆祝。我的意思是，我们玩得太开心了。我们在等着史蒂夫来派对。是的。所以情况是这样的。当节目结束时，每个人，我猜是从正在拍摄的内部走出来，他们鱼贯而出，实际上走进了我们所在的帐篷。是的。我想我们甚至都不知道这一点。你会觉得，哦天哪。史蒂夫拿着奖杯走了进来。我们扑向了他。然后我们开始和金球奖以及史蒂夫一起合影留念。我们脸上的表情，看起来
look maniacal. My favorite photo. My favorite photo is the photo. I know. I know what you're going to say. Where Angela had gotten her hand on the Golden Globe. Well, first of all, wait a second. We were all, Steve was letting us all hold it. Yeah. And I guess it was at People Magazine. They were taking pictures. There was this little photo booth that you could get into for People Magazine and we shoved the entire cast of the office into this photo booth. Angela's got the Golden Globe and she holds it above her head and goes, yeah, I like right at the moment that they snapped the picture. And when the
像个狂人。我最喜欢的照片。我最喜欢的照片是那张。我知道。我知道你要说什么。安吉拉把手搭在了金球奖上。好吧，首先，等一下。我们都在，史蒂夫让每个人都拿一下。是的。我猜那是《人物》杂志。他们在拍照。有一个《人物》杂志的小拍照亭，我们可以挤进去，然后我们把《办公室》的全体演员都塞进了这个拍照亭。安吉拉拿着金球奖，把它高举过头顶，喊着“耶”，就在他们按下快门的那一刻。当照片
picture came back, she is hitting Phyllis in the face. I hit Phyllis in the chin. It was a Golden Globe. And the photo actually shows her face contorted, like, oh. So funny. It's so funny. We have to post it. We have to post that picture. Phyllis, I'm so sorry. I hit you with Steve's Golden Globe. Oh my god. I blame Brian Baumgartner and the just pure happiness for Steve. Here's something really special too. Do you remember when we went back to work the next day at lunch, the catering department served lobster and steak for lunch? Oh, yeah. It was
洗出来时，她正打在菲莉丝的脸上。我打中了菲莉丝的下巴。那是金球奖。照片里甚至能看到她的脸扭曲着，像是在说“哦”。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。我们必须把它发出来。我们必须把那张照片发出来。菲莉丝，真的很对不起。我用史蒂夫的金球奖打到你了。哦天哪。我怪布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳，还有对史蒂夫纯粹的喜悦。还有一件特别的事情。你还记得第二天我们回去工作时，餐饮部门在午餐时提供龙虾和牛排吗？哦，是的。那是
surf and turf to celebrate. It was so decadent and it was really sweet. I know. I remember that and being like, do we have the budget for this? I know. What can we not do this week because we're eating this? Yeah. All right. Thanks for taking the detour down the Golden Globes Journal entries. Yeah, that was fun for us. We hope that was fun for you. I'm going to hitch up with a summary and then we'll take a break. Okay. So in the booze cruise episode, Jim told Michael about his crush on Pam. In this episode, Michael finds out he is the only person who knows the secret and he is delighted in the status that it gives him. So he
冲浪与草皮（海鲜牛排大餐）来庆祝。太奢侈了，真的很贴心。我懂。我记得那个，当时还想，我们的预算够吗？我知道。这周我们有什么不能做的，因为我们在吃这个？是的。好吧，谢谢你们陪我绕道金球奖日志。是的，这对我们来说很有趣。我们希望你们也觉得有趣。我来做一个总结，然后我们休息一下。好的。所以在“酒水游轮”那一集里，吉姆向迈克尔坦白了他对帕姆的迷恋。在这一集里，迈克尔发现自己是唯一知道这个秘密的人，他对自己因此获得的地位感到非常高兴。所以他
decides Jim must be his very best friend, that Jim must consider him his best friend since he told him this secret and he struggles the entire episode to keep the secret to himself. Also in this episode, it is spring cleaning day at the office. Oscar says he can't come to work because of the flu, which causes Dwight to start an investigation into whether or not he's really sick. There it is. That's a good one. And when we come back from the break, we will get into it. Angela, I think you have a little bit of up dog on your cards. What? You have some up dog on your cards. What's up dog? Not much. What's up with you? The
决定吉姆一定是他最好的朋友，吉姆既然把这个秘密告诉了他，就一定把他当成最好的朋友，于是他在整集里都在努力保守这个秘密。同样在这一集里，是办公室的大扫除日。奥斯卡说他因为流感不能来上班，这导致德 Dwight（德怀特）开始调查他是否真的生病了。就是这样。这个不错。当我们从休息回来后，我们将深入探讨。安吉拉，我觉得你的卡片上有一点“up dog（怎么啦）”。什么？你的卡片上有些“up dog”。什么是up dog？没啥。你呢？这集的
cold open of this episode. What's up dog? What's up dog? And Michael is so excited that he's part of this joke and that he gets it and he cannot wait to tell it over and over and it never works. He never gets anyone to ask until the end when Dwight finally says what's up dog and he forgets the punchline. He forgets the punchline and also I thought it's just one of those moments where rain is so cute as Dwight where he's sincerely like, oh thanks for asking. Yeah, thank you so much. Michael's like, ugh. I reached out to Leah Eisenberg, one of the writers of this episode, and he said that this up dog joke idea happened because this
冷开场。什么是up dog？什么是up dog？迈克尔太兴奋了，因为他是这个笑话的一部分，而且他懂这个梗，他迫不及待地一遍又一遍地讲，但却毫无效果。直到最后德怀特终于问出“什么是up dog”之前，从来没有人问过他，而他却忘了笑点。他忘了笑点，而且我觉得这也是展现雷恩作为德怀特时如此可爱的一个瞬间，他真诚地说，“哦，谢谢你问我。”是的，非常感谢。迈克尔心里想，呃。我联系了李·艾森伯格，这一集的编剧之一，他说这个up dog笑话的创意是因为
actually happened to those guys. Oh. Yes, they were on the receiving end of an up dog joke that wasn't landing and they always think that's what writers do. They observe things from their life and they pin it and they're like, I'm gonna put this somewhere one day and it went here. He also reminded me that there was an alternate cold open for this episode. What was it? Michael comes into work and he has purchased a new executive golf set. Yes. And he goes into his office with Dwight and they're trying to use this little putter and in the process his world's best boss mug breaks. Yes, and he has a replacement one right away. In his
这真的发生在他们这群人身上。哦。是的，他们曾是up dog笑话的接收方，但那个笑话没能成功逗乐大家，他们总觉得这就是编剧们的做法。他们观察生活中的事情，然后把它记下来，心想：总有一天我要把它用在某个地方，然后它就到了这里。他还提醒我，这一集本来还有一个替代的冷开场。是什么？迈克尔来到公司，买了一套新的行政高尔夫球具。是的。他和德怀特一起走进办公室，他们试图用那个小推杆，在这个过程中，他的“世界最佳老板”马克杯碎了。是的，他马上拿了一个替换的。在他的
desk and you can see this in the deleted scenes and I watched it. But what's fun is later in this episode, you're gonna see evidence of this golf set cold open that we replaced with the up dog. I'll keep you waiting. I have time codes and everything. I was gonna say about somebody's gonna be tracking the golf stuff. I'm gonna track it. Alright, so after the cold open, the episode begins. It's spring cleaning in January. It is. I have a little story about what happens over in the accounting department. Do you want to hear it? I do. Okay, so at one minute 56 seconds, you see Kevin. He's tossing things into the trash, but just
办公桌里，你可以在删减片段里看到这个，我看了。但有趣的是，在这一集的后面，你会看到这个高尔夫球具冷开场的证据，我们用up dog代替了它。我先卖个关子。我有时间码和所有东西。我本来要说有人会追踪高尔夫球的事。我要追踪它。好吧，冷开场之后，正片开始了。一月份进行大扫除。确实如此。我有一个小故事，关于会计部门发生了什么。你想听吗？我想听。好的，所以在1分56秒时，可以看到凯文。他把东西扔进垃圾桶，但方式
like really kind of haphazardly. My character is annoyed, you know, that he's throwing things away. He shouldn't be throwing away. Well, there is a scene that didn't make it. It's an improv scene. It's in the bloopers though. If you go on YouTube and look at season two bloopers, this is where you can find the scene. Kevin then starts digging in the trash because he realized he's thrown away things he probably shouldn't have. And he improvises, I need to go through this again. And then I improvise, but you guys, I sound so southern when you watch it. This is what I improvise. I do not believe you are engaged. I do not believe
有点随随便便的。我的角色很恼火，你知道的，他把不该扔的东西扔掉了。嗯，有一个场景没有剪进去。这是一个即兴表演的场景。不过它在花絮里。如果你去YouTube上查看第二季的花絮，就能找到这个场景。凯文接着开始在垃圾桶里翻找，因为他意识到自己扔了不该扔的东西。他即兴发挥说：“我得再翻一遍。”然后我即兴发挥，但是各位，你们听的时候，我的声音听起来太南方了。这就是我的即兴发挥。我不相信你订婚了。我不相信
it. That is a great improv. That's what I improv. I wish that made it in. What a good dig on Kevin. I know, right? Anyway, it's a really fun little blooper moment, and you can find those on YouTube. Also, Kelly is cleaning out magazines. We have half up, half down, Jenna, but barely, barely any up. It's like only her little front whispies. I don't know if it's too soon, but I kind of want to declare that we've hit Full Mindy. Full Mindy and personality, that she still has a little front part up, but still, this is now Mindy. But this updo, this half up, half downdo is completely different. It's not fussy. It's super stylish. Her clothes, I
它。这是一次非常棒的即兴发挥。那是我的即兴发挥。真希望它能被剪进去。真是对凯文绝妙的讽刺。我懂，对吧？无论如何，这是一个非常有趣的即兴小花絮，你可以在YouTube上找到它们。还有，凯利在清理杂志。我们是半扎起半放下，珍娜，但几乎没有扎起，几乎没有。就像她额头前的一小缕碎发。我不知道现在说是不是太早了，但我有点想宣布我们已经达到了“完全曼迪”状态。无论是“完全曼迪”的个性，她还是把前面的一小部分扎起来了一点，但不管怎样，这就是现在的曼迪。但这个发型，这个半扎半放的发型完全不同。一点也不繁琐。超级时尚。她的衣服，我
feel like, have really changed in this episode. Her personality? Her personality is 100% Full Mindy. I want to declare that it's Full Mindy, that the secret is Full Mindy. I'm scared to do it because I feel like there's more to come. I think there's more to come, but I'm willing to say we're pretty much there. We're 90% Full Mindy. We're 90% Full Mindy. I'll declare that. We're 90% Full Mindy, the secret. Lee told me also just fun fact, not a fast fact, a fun fact. This is super fun, that Lee's friend who works in San Francisco told him about having to do spring cleaning in his office, and they put this storyline in at the very last
觉得，在这集里真的变了。她的个性？她的个性是百分之百的“完全曼迪”。我想宣布这就是“完全曼迪”，这个秘密就是“完全曼迪”。我有点不敢这么说，因为我觉得后面还有更多。我觉得后面还会有更多，但我愿意说我们差不多已经达到了。我们有90%的“完全曼迪”。我们有90%的“完全曼迪”。我宣布这一点。我们有90%的“完全曼迪”，这个秘密。李还告诉我一个趣事，不是快讯，是一个趣事。这超级有趣，李在旧金山工作的朋友告诉他，他不得不在办公室里做大扫除，他们在最后一刻把
minute. They did not have a lot of turnaround on this episode. Once again, remember last time they told us that they barely got any kind of outline and they had to write their episode, and this time there was a super big rush on the episode. They only had like three to four days to write it. Usually you get a couple of weeks. They had to turn it around really quickly, and they needed some storyline for the whole office. They knew the secret storyline between Michael and Jim, and they knew the storyline about Oscar and the investigation about whether or not he was really sick, but they needed something
这个故事情节加了进去。他们这一集的制作周期非常短。再说一次，还记得上次他们告诉我们，他们几乎没有拿到任何大纲，就得写出剧本，而这一次，这一集的制作非常赶。他们只有大约三到四天的时间来写。通常你会有好几个星期。他们必须非常快地完成，而且他们需要为整个办公室安排一些故事情节。他们知道迈克尔和吉姆之间的秘密故事情节，也知道关于奥斯卡以及调查他是否真的生病的故事情节，但他们需要一些
for the rest of us to be doing. So he called Mike Scherr and he pitched this idea. My friend told me that he had to do spring cleaning at their office. I think I could make it really funny, and he wrote me and he said that Mike Scherr's response was, quote, if you have to, you have to. If you need it, do it. At two minutes, seven seconds, Jenna, you must have been so tickled. This is like your favorite thing where Michael's talking, and then we reveal two other people. Oh yeah. Not only are you getting a Dwight reveal, but then you get Ryan on the floor. Yeah. And he said, Michael says a cluttered desk is a cluttered mine. You
东西让剩下的我们去做。所以他打电话给迈克·舒尔，提出了这个想法。我的朋友告诉我，他必须在他们的办公室做大扫除。我想我可以把它写得非常搞笑，他写信给我说迈克·舒尔的回答是，原话：“如果必须的话，那就做吧。如果需要，就去做。”在2分07秒时，珍娜，你一定觉得太逗了。这就像你最喜欢的那种场景：迈克尔在说话，然后我们镜头一转，露出了另外两个人。哦，是的。不仅有德怀特的亮相，接着还有雷恩躺在地板上。是的。他说，迈克尔说，杂乱的桌子代表杂乱的思想。你
guys, my mom, Bernie Kinsey, would say this to me every week. She would say, Angela, a cluttered room is a cluttered mind, because my room would get messy. And when Michael said that, I was like, oh my god, it's my mom. It's my mom. Well, you mentioned the reveal of Ryan sitting on the floor. Mm-hmm. There is a deleted scene that explains why he's sitting on the floor, and it is he has two boxes, and one says keep, and one says trash. And he is sitting on Michael's floor going through all of Michael's things while Michael reads a newspaper. Yeah. Not cleaning at all. And he's like, this People magazine from 1994. And
大家，我妈妈伯尼·金西（Bernie Kinsey）每周都会对我说这个。她会说，安吉拉，杂乱的房间代表杂乱的心智，因为我的房间总是很乱。当迈克尔那么说时，我就想，哦天哪，这简直就是我妈妈。这简直就是我妈妈。好吧，你提到了瑞安坐在地上的那个镜头。嗯哼。有一个被删减的片段解释了为什么他坐在地上，那就是他有两个箱子，一个写着保留，一个写着垃圾。他坐在迈克尔的地板上，翻找迈克尔所有的东西，而迈克尔则在一旁看报纸。是的。根本没有在打扫。他拿起一本1994年的《人物》杂志，然后
Michael's like, keep, keep it. He's like, okay, he's like, I might do the crossword. And he's like, it's from 1994. Michael's like, I know, keep. There is nothing in the trash box. It's amazing. It's a fun little, fun little nugget. Alright, I need to talk about two minutes, 34 seconds, the very, very long stare between Dwight and Angela. Yeah. Dwight and Angela. Yeah. I have a fan question. Okay. From where are the turtles? Okay. The long stare with Dwight and Angela is so brilliant as our future stares. Is it hard to not crack up while filming those? Angela, tell us all about it. Yeah, it's hard not to crack up. I'm sure there's tons of footage of me
迈克尔说，留着，留着。他说，好吧，他说，我可能会做填字游戏。迈克尔说，这是1994年的。迈克尔说，我知道，留着。垃圾箱里什么都没有。这太神奇了。这是一个很有趣的小花絮。好吧，我需要谈谈两分三十四秒时，德怀特和安吉拉之间非常非常漫长的对视。是的。德怀特和安吉拉。是的。我有一个粉丝提问。好的。乌龟在哪里？好的。德怀特和安吉拉的长久对视真是太精彩了，就像我们未来的对视一样。在拍摄这些镜头时，是不是很难忍住不笑？安吉拉，给我们讲讲是怎么回事吧。是的，很难忍住不笑。我确信有很多我
getting tickled. And also, it was so fun. It is so fun. One thing I think we do in society is like, we know not to stare. We grow up, right? And our parents are like, don't stare, don't stare. And so all of a sudden, you're given permission to just stare at someone and draw it out as long as possible. There were times when I thought the director was going to yell cut because I'm like, surely they're done watching us stare at each other. And they're like, no, keep on going. It was really fun. But yeah, very hard to keep a straight face. And of course, having like Kevin there watching us like, what are you doing? Well, some context to the
被逗笑的花絮。而且，这也太有趣了。真的太有趣了。我认为我们在社会中做的一件事就是，我们知道不要盯着别人看。我们长大了，对吧？我们的父母会说，别盯着看，别盯着看。所以突然之间，你得到了允许，可以盯着某个人看，并且尽可能长时间地坚持下去。有时候我以为导演会喊停，因为我想，他们肯定已经看够我们互相瞪着对方了。但他们却说，不，继续下去。这真的很有趣。但是，是的，要保持扑克脸真的很难。当然，还有凯文在那里看着我们，好像在说，你们在干什么？好吧，关于这个
scene is that he comes up and says that Oscar is out sick and says something like that's unacceptable. And you say, I agree. It's unacceptable. And there is like some charged like you both are very aroused by your agreement that this is unacceptable. Oh, no, I put we get really turned on by unacceptable. Exactly. Exactly. Jenna, I have something to point out. My lady friend, what is it at two minutes, 50 seconds? When Dwight says Oscar is out sick, Michael says, and on a Friday, it's Friday again, a Friday and no one is dressed casually. Uh huh. Thank you for catching that. Yeah. I don't even know what to do with that. I don't even know
场景的一些背景是，他走过来宣布奥斯卡请病假了，并说这不可接受之类的话。然后你说，我同意。这不可接受。这其中带有一种电光火石般的张力，你们两个都对彼此认为这不可接受的观点感到非常兴奋。哦，不，我觉得我们对不可接受的事感到非常兴奋。完全正确。完全正确。珍娜，我有一点要指出来。我的好朋友，两分五十秒时是什么情况？当德怀特说奥斯卡请病假时，迈克尔说，而且是在周五，又是周五，周五却没有人穿便服。嗯哼。谢谢你发现了这一点。是的。我甚至不知道该拿这个怎么办。我甚至不知道
what to say about it. I don't know what to say about it. Four minutes, nine seconds. Pam and Kelly, Pam is planning her wedding. Kelly asks to be a bridesmaid. That is hilarious. I love that so much. Like, who has the audacity? Like, not even a really good friend to be like, Oh my God, can I be in your wedding? And she's like, you don't have to answer now. There's also so much going on in the scene because Pam takes her hair down and she floofs it out. And you can see Jim in the background over Kelly's shoulder. Poor Jim is what I wrote. Poor Jim. And then, you know, Michael comes out of his office and has
该怎么评价它。我不知道该怎么评价它。四分九秒。帕姆和凯莉，帕姆在筹备她的婚礼。凯莉要求当伴娘。这太搞笑了。我太喜欢了。天哪，谁有这么大的厚脸皮？甚至都不是特别好的朋友，竟然会说，哦天哪，我可以参加你的婚礼吗？然后帕姆说，你不用现在回答。这个场景里还有很多其他事情发生，因为帕姆把头发放下来，然后把它抓蓬松了。你可以看到吉姆在凯莉肩膀后面的背景里。我写的是：可怜的吉姆。可怜的吉姆。然后，你知道，迈克尔从他的办公室出来，并
to make a comment. It was, this was a tricky one to film. And I always want to point these scenes out because I just think they're really great examples of the choreography of our director, our camera operators. It's really something special to capture this stuff. Well, Michael says you should leave your hair down more because it's sexier. And then I walks past Jim and he goes, Oh, this must be so hard on you. Yeah. Way to make it all worse, Michael. Then we move on to a spy shot conversation between Jim and Michael in Michael's office. This is when Michael finds out that he is the only person who knows about Jim's
发表了评论。这是一个很难拍摄的场景。我总是想指出这些场景，因为我只是觉得它们是我们导演和摄像师场面调度极好的例子。捕捉这些东西真的是一件很特别的事。好吧，迈克尔说你应该多把头发放下来，因为这样更性感。然后我从吉姆身边走过，他说，哦，这对你来说一定很难熬吧。是的，迈克尔，你可真会把事情弄得更糟糕。接下来，我们转到吉姆和迈克尔在迈克尔办公室里的一场秘密谈话。这是迈克尔发现他是唯一一个知道吉姆
feelings for Pam. And I want you to notice that four minutes, 57 seconds, Michael is playing with a golf ball. Oh, yes, he is. That is because of that cold open that we cut out. Right. And he had all the golf stuff in his office. Yeah. Right. Well, Michael says something in this scene that I thought was so great. It's his talking head and Steve is so brilliant in it. He just talks about how special it is, you know, obviously that Jim shared with him and what good friends they are, blah, blah, blah. But his last sentence just made me laugh. He goes, And it is why I intend on keeping that secret for as long as I
对帕姆的感情的人的时候。我想让你注意到，在四分五十七秒时，迈克尔在玩高尔夫球。哦，是的，他确实在玩。那是因为我们剪掉的那段开场独白。没错。他办公室里有所有的高尔夫球装备。是的。没错。好吧，迈克尔在这个场景中说了一句话，我觉得太棒了。那是他的单人访谈，史蒂夫在其中的表现真是太精彩了。他只是谈到这有多么特别，你知道的，显然吉姆与他分享了秘密，以及他们是多么好的朋友，等等，等等。但他的最后一句话让我笑出声来。他说，这就是为什么我打算把这个秘密保守尽可能
possibly can. He totally owns that he sucks at keeping a secret. Yeah. You guys, my dad was someone who absolutely could not hold onto information. Now he was a wonderful friend and father and confidant, all of those things. But if there was like some great information, there was no way he could not like tell you or it just, it would be all over his face. Yeah. I had no poker face. When Steve said that, I just sort of chuckled and thought of my dad and how hard it was for him to like keep any news from us. Are you good with secrets? Are you more like your dad? I think I'm good. I think I'm good. I don't know, Jenna, you've
长的时间。他完全承认自己很不擅长保守秘密。是的。大家，我爸爸就是那种绝对守不住秘密的人。现在，他是一个非常棒的朋友、父亲和知己，所有这些都是。但如果有某种很棒的消息，他绝对做不到不告诉你，或者这会完全写在他的脸上。是的。我完全没有扑克脸。当史蒂夫这么说时，我只是咯咯笑了一下，想起了我爸爸，以及对他来说把任何消息对我们保密有多么困难。你擅长保守秘密吗？你更像你爸爸吗？我觉得我还行。我觉得我还行。不知道，珍娜，你认识我很久了。
known me a long time. I think you're good. Yeah. We had a fan question actually. It was Shanice who asked, Are you too good at keeping secrets? Do you have that one person that you just have to share it with because you trust them and that's okay? Yeah. Yeah. Well, anyone who tells me anything should know that I'm gonna tell Jenna. I am unless you like, if you're like, Hey, you can't say this to anyone. Yeah. Okay. And then I'm gonna tell my husband. I tell my husband everything. Like you have to really say, All right, you can't. And then I probably will at some point tell you or my husband. I might sit on it for a bit.
我觉得你很擅长。是的。其实我们有一个粉丝提问。是夏尼斯（Shanice）问的，你们两个很擅长保守秘密吗？你们有没有那种必须与之分享的人，因为你信任他们，而且这没关系？是的。是的。好吧，任何告诉我任何事的人都应该知道我会告诉珍娜。我会的，除非你像，如果你说，嘿，你不能把这个告诉任何人。是的。好的。然后我会告诉我丈夫。我什么都告诉我丈夫。就像你必须真正说，好吧，你不能。然后我可能在某个时候还是会告诉你或我丈夫。我可能会把这件事藏在心里一会儿。
But eventually, I mean, I honestly, I'm sitting here like thinking like, I don't know, Jenna, that I pretty much have to download everything to you. It's like kind of how I process information. I receive information. I know how I feel about it. But then like it either becomes more real or more clear to me once I share it with you or Josh. I feel the same way. You and Lee are the two people that I tell everything to. So if someone tells me something in confidence, I assume they know that they're telling me, Angela and Lee simultaneously. My best friend and my husband. That's right. However, I will say there are things that
但最终，我的意思是，老实说，我坐在这里心想，我不知道，珍娜，我几乎必须把所有事情都向你倾诉。这有点像我处理信息的方式。我接收信息。我知道我对它的感受。但随后，一旦我把它分享给你或乔希，它就会变得更真实或更清晰。我有同感。你和李是我倾诉一切的两个人。所以如果有人私下告诉我什么，我假设他们知道他们是在同时告诉我和李。我最好的朋友和我的丈夫。没错。不过，我要说的是，有些事情
you have told me, Angela, that I have not shared with Lee. And there are things that Lee has told me that I've not shared with you. Same. So I do. Those two people are like, they get special treatment. Yes, that's right. All the rest of y'all just know I'm blabbing to Lee and Angela, if you told me. Yeah. Unless you specifically tell me not to. And then similar to you, Angela, I will sit on it for a bit and then tell them anyway. Oh yeah. At five minutes, 43 seconds. Dwight goes up to Ryan and he wants, you know, Ryan basically to take over the spring cleaning stuff because he's got this investigation to conduct. Now, I
是你告诉我的，安吉拉，我没有告诉李。有些事情是李告诉我的，我没有告诉你。我也是。所以我确实如此。这两个人就像是得到了特殊待遇。是的，没错。你们其他人只要知道，如果你们告诉我了，我就会对李和安吉拉大嘴巴。是的。除非你明确告诉我不要。然后和你一样，安吉拉，我会把这件事藏在心里一会儿，然后不管怎样还是会告诉他们。哦，是的。在五分四十三秒时。德怀特走向瑞安，他希望，你知道的，瑞安基本上接管大扫除的事情，因为他要进行这项调查。现在，我
did a ton of scenes with Rainn Wilson and Rainn loves a prop. And once he gets a prop, he's very attached to a prop. So he did this thing in the scene that made me laugh so hard. He walks up to Ryan, he has his little notepad he's writing in. Yeah. And as he walks up to Ryan, he takes it out of his jacket pocket and he flashes it at Ryan as if it's like a badge. You have to wash it. It's a very subtle move. It's just a notepad. It looks like one of those notepads that you win for 200 tickets at Chuck E. Cheese. Exactly. Yeah. Exactly. So he's like, I'm conducting a little investigation. He flashes the notepad.
和雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）拍了大量的戏，雷恩非常喜欢道具。一旦他拿到了道具，他就对道具非常依恋。所以他在这个场景里做了一件事，把我逗得哈哈大笑。他走向瑞安，手里拿着他的小笔记本在写东西。是的。当他走向瑞安时，他把它从夹克口袋里掏出来，在瑞安面前晃了一下，就好像它是一个徽章一样。你得看看它。这是一个非常微妙的动作。这只是一个笔记本。它看起来就像你在查克E奶酪（Chuck E. Cheese）赢得200张奖券的那种笔记本。没错。是的。没错。所以他说，我在进行一个小调查。他晃了晃笔记本。
Like that is going to be like, oh, okay, this is legit. Yeah. To Ryan. And Ryan, of course, is just like, ugh. So then we move to the vending machines. Mm hmm. Michael is trying to talk to Jim more about his love of Pam at the vending machines and Stanley enters. Oh, gosh. And Stanley is taking forever to pick a beverage. He is. Just forever. And he's in the way. And Michael is trying so much to capitalize on this bonding time with Jim. Yeah. He's like, we're best friends. We share secrets. I want, I just want to spend now as much time as possible with him. I want to chat about his love for Pam. I want him to know I'm a great
就好像那会让人觉得，哦，好吧，这是合法的。是的。对瑞安而言。而瑞安，当然是一副，呃的表情。然后我们转移到自动售货机。嗯哼。迈克尔正试图在自动售货机旁和吉姆多聊聊他对外表帕姆的爱慕，这时斯坦利进来了。哦，天哪。斯坦利挑饮料花了好长时间。他真的是。花了好长时间。而且他挡路了。迈克尔非常想利用这段和吉姆培养感情的时间。是的。他说，我们是最好的朋友。我们分享秘密。我想，我现在只想花尽可能多的时间和他在一起。我想聊聊他对帕姆的爱慕。我想让他知道我是一个伟大的
friend. At the end of that scene, Michael like just picks an item for Stanley and it's peach iced tea. And then Steve says, you're going to hate it. That was improvised. And that was a moment that a lot of people wrote in about when I asked, what do you want us to talk about for this moment was the peach iced tea? You're going to hate it. And it was an improvised moment. It was so great. And also in that scene, John could not stop laughing. He could not stop laughing. This whole episode, he had to spend a lot of time with Steve doing scenes. And John really loses it. So this was one of those scenes. John, when he loses it, his whole
朋友。在那场戏的最后，迈克尔直接为斯坦利挑选了一款商品，那是桃子冰茶。然后史蒂夫说，你会讨厌它的。那是即兴发挥的。当我问大家，你想让我们聊聊这个时刻的什么时，很多人写信来谈论的就是桃子冰茶？你会讨厌它的。这是一个即兴发挥的时刻。太棒了。而且在那场戏中，约翰笑得停不下来。他笑得停不下来。整集节目中，他都不得不花很多时间与史蒂夫一起拍戏。而约翰真的彻底失控了。所以这也是其中一场戏。约翰一旦失控，他的整具
body collapses. Yeah. He just becomes a noodle. At six minutes, 58 seconds, my background observers out there, I need your help. Dwight is calling Oscar again. Poor Oscar. Dwight's just like calling him like crazy. But as he's sitting on his desk, he's on the phone behind him. Okay. So the hand that's holding the phone, look at the hand holding the phone. Look behind his hand. It's like a file cabinet next to Phyllis's desk. There is a hairy object. It's a black hairy object. What is it? Look, wait, Sam, can you pull up six minutes, 58 seconds? I kind of need Jenna to see it. There it is. You got it. Look at it. I see nothing. What are you talking
身体都会瘫软下来。是的。他简直变成了一根面条。在六分五十八秒时，背景观察员们，我需要你们的帮助。德怀特又在给奥斯卡打电话了。可怜的奥斯卡。德怀特就像疯了一样给他打电话。但当他坐在办公桌前时，他正在打身后的电话。好吧。所以拿着电话的那只手，看看拿着电话的那只手。看他手后面。就像菲莉丝办公桌旁边的文件柜。有一个毛茸茸的物体。那是一个黑色的毛茸茸的物体。那是什么？看，等等，山姆，你能调出六分五十八秒吗？我有点需要珍娜看到它。就是那个。你找到了。看它。我什么也没看到。你在说什么
about? What is that? What is that? It looks like a wig on a wig stand. I know. On a file cabinet next to Phyllis. I'm gonna get up and I'm gonna physically look closer. Okay, we've looked at it in Jenna's picture. I know what it is and look at what Cody is holding in the booth. Look through the window. Do you see Cody? Cody's our producer. Yeah, what is that thing? A feather duster. Stop it. Are you sure? Feather duster. Really? Yeah. I think Phyllis has a feather duster as part of her spring cleaning and I think that's what it is. Oh, that's a good call. And also, Cody, where the heck are you? Cody, where did you get a feather duster just now?
呢？那是什么？那是什么？它看起来像个假人头上的假发。我知道。在菲莉丝旁边的文件柜上。我要站起来，我要亲自仔细看看。好吧，我们在珍娜的照片里看过了。我知道那是什么，看看科迪在小隔子里拿着什么。透过窗户看。你看到科迪了吗？科迪是我们的制片人。是的，那是什么东西？鸡毛掸子。住手。你确定吗？鸡毛掸子。真的吗？是的。我想菲莉丝有一个鸡毛掸子作为她大扫除的一部分，我想这就是那个东西。哦，这个解释得好。而且，科迪，你到底在哪里？科迪，你刚才从哪里弄来的鸡毛掸子？
It's like your carrot top and you have a truck full of random props. Guys, Cody is a little bit like me. I think she is very organized and structured and I believe she might walk around with a feather duster. Well, we've never seen it before. Where is she keeping it? Oh my god. All right. Sorry, sorry to take us down that road but that was making me crazy last night. At seven minutes 34 seconds, again, Michael, desperate to connect more with Jim. He's so excited about having a friend. He's following him around like a little puppy. He is and he walks up to him and he goes, it's grape soda because he got a grape soda too because Jim got a
这就像你是胡萝卜头（Carrot Top），你有一卡车的随机道具。伙计们，科迪有点像我。我觉得她非常有条理、很有规划，我相信她可能随时带着鸡毛掸子走来走去。好吧，我们以前从没见过它。她把它藏在哪儿了？哦，天哪。好吧，抱歉，抱歉把大家带到这个方向，但这昨晚把我快逼疯了。在七分三十四秒时，迈克尔再次渴望与吉姆建立更多联系。他对能有一个朋友感到非常兴奋。他像一只小狗一样到处跟着他。他是的，他朝他走去，他说，这是葡萄苏打水，因为他也拿了一罐葡萄苏打水，因为吉姆拿了一罐
grape soda. So adorable. In this section, Dwight approaches and asks what's going on and then Jim keeps putting post-it notes on Dwight. And fan question from Tabitha, was the post-it notes on Dwight improvised? I believe it was. I think that was John. It's so perfect though. It is so perfectly their relationship and then Rain, you know, as Dwight would like try to stick it back on him. Yeah. It was just perfect. Yes. At eight minutes 46 seconds, Steve puts his leg up on Jim's desk. He puts his foot on top of his desk and leans forward. Like, leans really, really his crotch. Into Jim's face. And John lost it. I was there that day filming. John could
葡萄苏打水。太可爱了。在这个部分，德怀特走过来问怎么回事，然后吉姆不断地把便利贴贴在德怀特身上。来自塔比莎（Tabitha）的粉丝提问，德怀特身上的便利贴是即兴发挥的吗？我相信是的。我认为那是约翰的主意。不过这太完美了。这完全就是他们之间的关系，然后雷恩，你知道的，作为德怀特，试图把它粘回吉姆身上。是的。简直太完美了。是的。在八分四十六秒时，史蒂夫把一条腿抬到吉姆的办公桌上。他把一只脚踩在桌子顶部，然后身体前倾。就像是，把他的胯部非常非常用力地
not stop laughing. Very similar to Diversity Day, Angela, when you and I were in the conference room and Steve straddled the chair. And leaned forward to us. Yeah. Really. And part of it too was that that desk is really high and it was not super easy for Steve to put his leg up there. And his dress pants. But he was super committed to the bit. It was something he just came up with and it made John laugh. So then he kept doing it. But I think it was like, that was not easy. No, the desk is really high. You have to be very flexible to pull that off. So kudos to you, Steve, for being so committed to that bit. Well, I wrote about
凑到吉姆脸前。然后约翰笑崩了。我那天就在现场拍摄。约翰根本
this as well. And I said that you guys, Steve always found ways as Michael to put his feet up on things or just really sort of push a physical comfort zone that you have with another person. Yeah. He always thought that was like sort of as Michael a really funny gimmick. And it got us every time. I just think at eight minutes, 55 seconds, it's just kind of funny to me that Kevin is just walking over a different reception and just setting boxes down in front of Pam. I know. Thanks. What am I doing with those? I don't know. I guess that's my problem now. Kevin doing. So next guys, Michael decides to take Jim out to lunch. Well,
也写了关于这个的内容。我说你们，史蒂夫总是能找到作为迈克尔把脚翘在东西上的方法，或者只是真正地去挑战你与另一个人之间的身体舒适区。是的。他总是认为这作为迈克尔来说是一个非常有趣的噱头。每一次都把我们逗乐了。我只是觉得在八分五十五秒时，对我来说挺搞笑的一点是，凯文只是走到另一个前台，然后把一箱箱东西放在帕姆面前。我知道。谢谢。我拿这些东西怎么办？我不知道。我想现在那是我的问题了。凯文在干什么。所以接下来，大家，迈克尔决定带吉姆出去吃午饭。嗯，
Jim is just trying to get him out of the office so he doesn't spill the beans in front of Pam. So I don't think Jim would ever want to go out to lunch with Michael, especially to where he takes him. Hooters. Hooters. They go to Hooters. Oh, I have so many feelings about it, Angela. I know you do, honey. When I was watching it, guys, I'm not going to lie to you, not a fan of the restaurants of this nature. Well, did you read their origin story? It was like when five, I'm paraphrasing guys. I did. I went to the Hooters website. I had to spend a lot of time on the Hooters website. Yeah. More time than I wish I did. Well, it's
吉姆只是想把他弄出办公室，这样他就不会在帕姆面前说漏嘴了。所以我认为吉姆绝不会想和迈克尔一起出去吃午饭，尤其是去他带去的地方。猫头鹰餐厅（Hooters）。猫头鹰餐厅。他们去了猫头鹰餐厅。哦，我对此有太多的感受了，安吉拉。我知道你有，亲爱的。当我在看的时候，伙计们，我不打算对你们撒谎，我不是这种性质的餐厅的粉丝。好吧，你读过他们的起源故事吗？就像五个，我是在转述大家的观点。我读了。我上了猫头鹰餐厅的网站。我不得不在猫头鹰餐厅的网站上花了很多时间。是的。比我希望的时间还要多。好吧，这是
something like when a group of five guys who kept getting kicked out of places decided to, they wanted, you know, pretty girls and hot wings. So anyway, listen, for the y'all folks out there that enjoy Hooters, that, that's, that. That's for you. That's for you. Okay. Okay. Anyway, we did have a fan question from Rob M. Did you shoot in a real Hooters and were they real Hooters waitresses? Yes. We filmed in a real Hooters. And yes, they were real Hooters waitresses, except for the main waitress, Dana, that she was played by an actress. That's right. Dana is played by Lindsay Stoddard, who is a really funny actress writer, improviser.
某种情况，就像当五个总是被赶出去的家伙决定，他们想要，你知道的，漂亮的女孩和辣翅。所以无论如何，听着，对于喜欢猫头鹰餐厅的朋友们，那就是，那样。那是给你们的。那是给你们的。好吧。好吧。无论如何，我们确实有一个来自罗姆·M（Rob M.）的粉丝提问。你们是在真正的猫头鹰餐厅拍摄的吗，她们真的是猫头鹰餐厅的服务员吗？是的。我们在真正的猫头鹰餐厅拍摄的。是的，她们确实是真正的猫头鹰餐厅的服务员，除了主要的服务员达娜（Dana），她是由女演员扮演的。没错。达娜由林赛·斯托达德（Lindsay Stoddard）饰演，她是一个非常搞笑的女演员、作家和即兴喜剧演员。
I knew her back in my IO days, in Provolympic days. And this Hooters in particular was in Burbank. Yep. That they filmed in. It is now closed. It's out of business. So you can't go there. Not shedding tears. And of course, Michael had to say chicken breast, hold the chicken. Yeah. That's a classic moment. But I love Dana's response, which is, is that really what you want? Yeah. And he's like, no, gourmet hot dog. But let me say something. Jim orders a ham and cheese. Michael orders a gourmet hot dog. I could not find either of these items on the online Hooters menu. I couldn't. I don't know. Guys, anyone who's gone to Hooters, do they serve
我在我以前的IO（ImprovOlympic）时期、即兴奥运会时期就认识她了。特别是这个猫头鹰餐厅位于伯班克（Burbank）。是的，他们就是在那里拍摄的。它现在已经关门了。已经倒闭了。所以你不能去那儿了。我不会为之流泪的。当然，迈克尔不得不说鸡胸肉，不要鸡肉。是的。这是一个经典时刻。但我喜欢达娜的回应，那就是，这真的是你想要的吗？是的。然后他说，不，特色热狗。但让我说点什么。吉姆点了一个火腿奶酪三明治。迈克尔点了一个特色热狗。我在网上猫头鹰餐厅的菜单上找不到这两样东西。我找不到。我不知道。伙计们，去过猫头鹰餐厅的人，他们提供
ham and cheese and or a gourmet hot dog? I would actually love to know. Do you know what I noticed? I noticed the girls look like they have to wear pantyhose under their short. Yes, they do. And I, I did a deep dive on Hooters. They do. They do wear pantyhose, pantyhose. That would listen. I would be for that. I would, I like that. I like it that it's not their bare leg. So I do appreciate that there's that. I just don't like pantyhose. So, well, we know. We know. Guys, if not for that, Angela might have worked at a Hooters, but the pantyhose thing, she was like, no. I'm fine with the tank top, but you lost me at the pantyhose. Fan comment from Rick Wilson, he pointed out that there is no Hooters in Scranton. There are not any Hooters in Scranton. I googled it. It's true. I googled it as well. There are two Hooters in Pennsylvania, one in Concordville and one in King of Prussia. Okay. So that's where you can go.
火腿奶酪还是，或者一个美食热狗？其实我很想知道。你知道我注意到什么了吗？我注意到那些女孩的短裤里面好像都得穿连裤袜。是的，她们确实穿。而且我，我深入研究了一下“猫头鹰”餐厅。她们确实穿。她们确实穿连裤袜，连裤袜。听着。我会支持这个的。我会的，我喜欢这样。我喜欢这不是她们的裸腿。所以我真的很赞赏这一点。我只是不喜欢连裤袜。所以，好吧，我们懂。我们懂。伙计们，如果不是因为这个，安吉拉可能已经在“猫头鹰”餐厅工作了，但那个连裤袜的事情，她当时就想，不了。我对背心没意见，但你在连裤袜这儿把我给劝退了。来自里克·威尔逊的粉丝评论，他指出斯克兰顿没有“猫头鹰”餐厅。斯克兰顿没有任何“猫头鹰”餐厅。我谷歌了一下。这是真的。我也谷歌了一下。宾夕法尼亚州有两家“猫头鹰”餐厅，一家在康科德维尔，一家在普鲁士王。好吧。所以这就是你能去的地方。
Fan question from Ryan Ritter. Is it true that the Hooters girls singing the happy birthday song was an added bit? No. This was scripted. You put your front side in. You put your front side out. Okay. Here's the thing. This seems like an old birthday tradition. At Hooters. At Hooters. Okay. And they don't say put your front side in. The real song is put your Hooters in, put your Hooters out. Oh. And then they shake them all about. They get in a circle around the birthday boy. And shake their tatas at them. Right. And then they put their backside in, put their backside out, and shake that all about. That's their butt. That's right, Angela. Yes. That's their butt. Okay. So. So it's sort of like an inappropriate hokey pokey. Correct. Okay. But that seems to be the old birthday policy, although I did find a video from as recent as 2015 where they were still doing this down in Georgia. But the main birthday song is where now they dress you up like an owl. Okay. They give you a beak and they give you some menus and you have to flap your wings and then all the Hooters girls like sing that it's your birthday, it's your birthday today, birthday. Sort of like that. I have one fan question that I forgot to cover from Ben Shown. Does John actually like ham and cheese sandwiches? Guys, I texted John. Oh, you're like a text. By the way, you're on a real role. You texted Steve about, what was it? Something so random? If he had a fake foot in the injury. Yeah. And now you're like, John, do you really like ham and cheese? We're going to start alienating people. John wrote me back and said he does, especially when the brats. Bread is toasted. Okay. There you go. There you go. I have something at 10 minutes, 14 seconds. It is rain as Dwight eating only the black jelly beans. Yeah. Or like the purple ones. I mean, was that in the script? It seems like something rain would do because he likes to kind of be gross. It was in the script and he had to chew a bunch of them before we started and kind of stick the half bits up into his teeth. We had a fan question from Janelle. Does rain actually like black jelly beans? Tell me you didn't text him. I texted him. Oh no. Oh my God. And he does. Oh, well, that's a relief. That's a relief. I have a question for you. In this scene, I guess Dwight tells you there's three ways to sniffle. Yeah. Because he's trying to figure out if Oscar is lying, right? Yeah. And I said, he sounded like he was telling the truth. I mean, he was sniffling when he called. And then he's like, what type of sniffle? And you're like, are there types? And he's like, there are three types of sniffles. And then Pam says it was the second one. Yeah. And Dwight's like, okay.
来自瑞安·里特的粉丝提问。“猫头鹰”餐厅的女孩们唱生日快乐歌是后来加的桥段吗？不是。这是有剧本的。你把正面伸进去。你把正面拿出来。好吧。事情是这样的。这看起来像是一个古老的生日传统。在“猫头鹰”餐厅。在“猫头鹰”餐厅。好吧。而且他们不说把正面伸进去。真正的歌词是把你们的猫头鹰伸进去，把你们的猫头鹰拿出来。哦。然后把它们全身摇一摇。她们围成一个圈站在寿星周围。把她们的胸部朝向他抖动。对。然后她们把背面伸进去，把背面拿出来，然后把那个全身摇一摇。那是她们的屁股。没错，安吉拉。是的。那是她们的屁股。好吧。所以。所以这有点像一个不合时宜的假动作游戏。没错。好吧。但这似乎是旧的生日政策，不过我确实找到了一个2015年的最新视频，他们当时在佐治亚州还在这样做。但主要的生日歌是现在他们把你打扮成一只猫头鹰。好吧。他们给你一个喙，给你一些菜单，你必须扇动你的翅膀，然后所有的“猫头鹰”餐厅女孩就会唱今天是你的生日，今天是你的生日，生日。差不多就这样。我有一个漏掉的本·肖恩的粉丝提问。约翰真的喜欢火腿奶酪三明治吗？伙计们，我给约翰发了短信。哦，你就像发短信。顺便说一句，你最近真的很活跃。你给史蒂夫发短信问，是什么来着？这么随意的怪事？他受伤时是不是装了个假脚。是的。而现在你就像是，约翰，你真的喜欢火腿奶酪吗？我们要开始疏远大家了。约翰回信给我说他确实喜欢，尤其是当香肠。面包烤过之后。好吧。给你。就这样。我有10分钟14秒时的一个片段。那是瑞恩扮演的德怀特只吃黑色果冻豆。是的。或者紫色的。我的意思是，那是剧本里的吗？这看起来像瑞恩会做的事，因为他喜欢表现得有点恶心。这在剧本里，他开始前得嚼上一堆，然后把半块塞进牙缝里。我们有一个来自珍妮尔的粉丝提问。瑞恩真的喜欢黑色果冻豆吗？告诉我你没给他发短信。我给他发短信了。哦，不。天哪。他确实喜欢。哦，好吧，这算是一种解脱。这算是一种解脱。我有个问题要问你。在这个场景中，我猜德怀特告诉你吸鼻涕有三种方式。是的。因为他想弄清楚奥斯卡是不是在撒谎，对吧？是的。我说，他听起来像是在说实话。我的意思是，他打电话时一直在吸鼻子。然后他说，什么类型的吸鼻涕？然后你就像是，还有好几种类型？然后他说，吸鼻涕有三种类型。然后潘说那是第二种。是的。然后德怀特就像是，好吧。
He's like, was that so hard? But also he does. You say it was the second one as if he has told you what the three of them are. I think that's amazing writing. Oh my gosh. It's amazing writing. All right, should we go to break? Let's go to break. Okay, so we are back from break. Yeah. And on break, you guys, I was talking a little bit of Game of Thrones with Sam. Because Angela loves to just alienate and torture me. No. And I mentioned Khaleesi. Tell him what you said. I said Khaleesi. Isn't that a virus? Khaleesi virus. No. It is a virus. I'm telling you, it's a virus that cats get. It is. 100% is. It's called Khaleesi virus. And it's like, just I'm looking at Kelly. Khaleesi is Queen Daenerys Targaryen. Okay. She's the lady of Dragstone, the protector of the seven kingdoms, the unburnt. You're saying nonsense to me. Feline Khaleesi virus. How do you spell it? C-A-L-I-C-I virus. Khaleesi virus is a virus of the family Khaleesi variety that causes diseases in cats. It's a respiratory infection. Khaleesi is a respiratory infection in cats. This Khaleesi was married to Cal Drogo and it's spelled K-H-A-L-E-E-S-I. She's the mother of dragons. She is not a cat virus. To me, she's not a cat virus. Stop it. She's not a cat virus. How dare you. Tell my cat that. Stop it. He had it. Gross.
他就像是，这有那么难吗？但他也确实。你说那是第二种，就好像他已经把那三种分别是什么告诉你了一样。我觉得这写得太妙了。哦，天哪。这写得太绝了。好了，我们该去休息一下吗？我们去休息一下吧。好吧，我们休息回来了。是的。在休息的时候，伙计们，我和萨姆聊了一会儿《权力的游戏》。因为安吉拉喜欢孤立和折磨我。不。我提到了龙母。告诉他你说了什么。我说龙母。那不是一种病毒吗？龙母病毒。不。这就是一种病毒。我跟你说，这是猫会得的一种病毒。是的。100%是的。它叫猫杯状病毒。它就像，我正看着凯莉。龙母是丹妮莉丝·坦格利安女王。好吧。她是龙石岛的主人，七大国守护者，不焚者。你对我说的是无稽之谈。猫杯状病毒。你怎么拼它？C-A-L-I-C-I病毒。猫杯状病毒是杯状病毒家族的一种病毒，会导致猫患病。这是一种呼吸道感染。猫杯状病毒是猫的一种呼吸道感染。这个龙母嫁给了卡奥·卓戈，它是这样拼的：K-H-A-L-E-E-S-I。她是龙之母。她不是猫病毒。对我来说，她不是猫病毒。住手。她不是猫病毒。你怎么敢。去跟我猫说。住手。他得过这病。真恶心。
Right. We're back to the episode, everybody. 11 minutes, 54 seconds. Oh my gosh. What? Ryan's talking head about how he could basically disappear from Dunder Mifflin in five seconds. Yeah. Have you had a job like that? Every job I had before I became a working actor was that job. I had a temp job at Disney and I had a cubicle. I'd never even personalized it. Anyway, you wouldn't even know I had been there. Oh man. I engaged very little in my day jobs when I was a struggling actor.
对。大家，我们回到剧集。11分钟54秒。哦，天哪。什么？瑞安的独白，讲他如何在五秒钟内从邓德米夫林神秘消失。是的。你有过那种工作吗？在我成为专业演员之前，我所有的工作都是那样的。我在迪士尼有一份临时工，我有一个小隔间。我甚至从来没个性化装扮过它。总之，你甚至都不会知道我去过那儿。天哪。当我是一个苦苦挣扎的演员时，我极少投入到我的日常工作中。
Did you not talk to people? I talked to people a little bit, but I didn't really make friends if I'm being honest. I did not want to put down any roots. I was Ryan. I get it. I get it. All right. At 13 minutes. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. What? You're jumping ahead and one of my favorite moments of the whole episode.
你都不跟人说话吗？我跟人说一点话，但说实话，我并没有真正交朋友。我不想扎根。我就是瑞安。我懂。我懂。好吧。在13分钟。等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。什么？你跳得太快了，这是整集中我最喜欢的时刻之一。
Is what? 12 minutes, 16 seconds. One of my favorite moments of this whole entire episode. Amazing. Michael tries to make his hair look like Jim's. It's amazing. It's absolutely incredible. And then he walks around like that for the rest of the episode. It's how he wears his hair sometimes. Yeah.
是什么？12分钟16秒。这是整集里我最喜欢的时刻之一。太棒了。迈克尔试图让他的头发看起来像吉姆的。太棒了。这绝对难以置信。然后他在接下来的剧集里一直顶着这个发型走来走去。他有时就是这样梳头。是的。
Guys, I do this sometimes. What's the big deal? At 12 minutes, 27 seconds. I've seen with Michael. Yeah. I think my character always kept him accountable. Yeah. And he probably didn't like it. So.
伙计们，我有时也这么做。这有什么大不了的？在12分钟27秒。我见过迈克尔。是的。我觉得我的角色总是让他负起责任。是的。他可能不喜欢这样。所以。
He's trying to expense his Hooters launch. Yeah. And I'm like, this is from Hooters. I'm like, did Toby approve it? And he's like, I don't have to run everything by Toby. You know, he gets really annoyed. Yes. The immediate next scene is us standing in front of Toby.
他试图把他的“猫头鹰”餐厅午餐报销。是的。然后我说，这是从“猫头鹰”餐厅来的。我说，托比批准了吗？然后他说，我不用什么事都经托比批准。你知道的，他真的很恼火。是的。紧接着的下一个场景就是我们站在托比面前。
I'll tell you a scene I would have loved to witness. I would have loved to see an angel in like, oh really? And march her butt across the office. Yes. And Michael like, no, like running after her like, Angela, you don't have to show Toby, Angela. And I'm like, I am showing Toby. Toby, we'll see this receipt.
我跟你说一个我很想亲眼目睹的场景。我真的很想看到安吉拉像，哦真的吗？然后大步流星地穿过办公室。是的。迈克尔就像，不，像追着她跑一样，安吉拉，你不用给托比看，安吉拉。而我却像，我就是要给托比看。托比，你会看到这张收据的。
And in that scene, it is revealed that his credit card was recently taken away because he made a big purchase at a magic store. He spent $80 at a magic store in his corporate card. And he says he almost closed a sale by doing one of those tricks at 12 minutes, 38 seconds. When Michael is explaining this in the talking head, if you look at his thumb, he's wearing a fake magic thumb. Oh, that's a good catch. It is a delicious detail.
而在那个场景中，人们发现他的信用卡最近被收回了，因为他在魔术店买了个大件。他在 корпоративная卡（公司的卡）上花80美元买了个魔术道具。他说他通过在12分钟38秒时表演其中一个戏法，差点就谈成了一笔生意。当迈克尔在独白中解释这一点时，如果你看他的大拇指，他戴着一个假魔术大拇指。哦，这个细节抓得好。这是一个极妙的细节。
That is a great catch. It is in the scene at Toby's desk where Michael spills the beans about Jim's secret. He says, I'm sorry. I had to take him in lunch because Jim is in love with a girl he works with who's engaged. And Kelly overhears and says, you mean Pam and Angela overhears and the secret is out. The secret is out. And when Michael realizes the secret is out, Steve's look to camera, he's like dead inside. He's like, oh no, I've done it.
这个细节抓得太棒了。就是在托比办公桌旁的那场戏，迈克尔说漏嘴了吉姆的秘密。他说，我很抱歉。我不得不带他去吃午餐，因为吉姆爱上了他工作的一个女孩，而她已经订婚了。凯利无意中听到并说，你是说潘，安吉拉也无意中听到，秘密泄露了。秘密泄露了。当迈克尔意识到秘密泄露时，史蒂夫对镜头的眼神，他看起来心如死灰。他就像，哦不，我闯祸了。
And this scene was really hard to get through, you guys. We were, we kept cracking up. When we realize that it's Pam and Michael leaves, the camera pans over to Kelly and my character. And I'm sort of like biting my lip. You have a little smirky smirk. I have a smirk for information. I also was trying not to laugh. Yeah.
这个场景真的很难拍过去，伙计们。我们，我们一直忍不住大笑。当我们意识到那是潘而且迈克尔离开时，镜头平移到凯利和我的角色身上。我有点在咬嘴唇。你露出了一个狡黠的微笑。我为了套取信息露出了微笑。我当时也极力忍住不笑。是的。
It's like all of those things. Well, the next scene is you and Phyllis cleaning out the fridge. And in this scene, Angela, when given the choice between Jim and Roy. Well, first of all, I love that I'm like, it's no one's business Phyllis, right? I first, I like admonish her. Yeah. Phyllis, stay out of it. Phyllis.
就像所有这些一样。好吧，接下来的场景是你和菲利斯在清理冰箱。在这个场景中，安吉拉，当在吉姆和罗伊之间做出选择时。好吧，首先，我喜欢我说这不关任何人的事，菲利斯，对吧？我首先，我喜欢训斥她。是的。菲利斯，少管闲事。菲利斯。
Be a better person. And then when my back is to her, I'm like, Roy. Roy. And again, it's like that same like weird arousal that we saw in the stair with Dwight. You like an alpha male. Angela Martin likes an alpha. Angela Martin liked a big guy that throws weight around. That's right.
做一个更好的人。然后当我的背对着她时，我喊了，罗伊。罗伊。而且再次，这就像我们在楼梯间和德怀特在一起时看到的那种奇怪的春心萌动。你喜欢阿尔法男。安吉拉·马丁喜欢阿尔法。安吉拉·马丁喜欢那种大块头、很有分量的人。没错。
So this leads to 13 minutes, 37 seconds. This is John Krasinski's favorite line of the entire series. He lost it when he saw it, when Creed says, which one is Pam? John loved Creed, the character Creed. Yes. He loves Creed and we're like, but the character Creed would make John disintegrate. I traded messages with Lee Eisenberg. I said earlier, Lee wrote that line, which one is Pam?
所以这就引出了13分钟37秒。这是约翰·卡拉辛斯基在整个系列中最喜欢的台词。当他看到它时，他笑崩了，当时克里德说，哪一个是潘？约翰很喜欢克里德，克里德这个角色。是的。他喜欢克里德，而我们却想，但克里德这个角色会把约翰整崩溃。我和李·艾森伯格发过信息。我刚才说过，李写了那句台词，哪一个是潘？
He said it is his favorite joke he ever wrote on the show and the one he is most proud of. I think that is great. So give him all the credit for that. Way to go, Lee. At 13 minutes, 54 seconds, we have a talking head inside of Dwight's car outside of Oscar's house. Did you notice the snow on the ground? Oh, I did.
他说这是他在剧里写过的最喜欢的笑话，也是他最引以为傲的一个。我觉得这太棒了。所以把所有的功劳都归功于他吧。干得好，李。在13分钟54秒，我们在奥斯卡家外面的德怀特车里有一段独白。你注意到地上的雪了吗？哦，我注意到了。
I did. And I noticed the camera couldn't pan too far past the sidewalk of that house because then it was just solid green grass. That's right. But come on, great production design guys. So next we have Jim's talking head where he explains he quote used to have a crush on Pam. So fan question from Monica Dadashi.
我注意到了。我还注意到镜头无法把取景框拉得太远，超过那栋房子的走道，因为那边全都是坚实翠绿的草坪。没错。但是，得了吧，制作设计真的很棒，伙计们。所以接下来是吉姆的独白，他解释说他“曾经暗恋过潘”。所以来自莫妮卡·达达什的粉丝提问。
In this episode, when Jim says he had a crush on Pam when she first started working at Dunder Mifflin, later in launch party, Jim says that when he started working there, Pam said to enjoy this moment because he could never go back to the time before he met Dwight. So which one is it? Who started working there first? Jim or Pam? Latimania and Joel Huber had a very long Twitter exchange about this continuity error. A lot of people wrote in about it.
在本集中，当吉姆说他刚开始在邓德米夫林工作时暗恋潘，后来在派对策划中，吉姆说当他开始工作时，潘对他说要享受这一刻，因为他再也回不到遇到德怀特之前的时光了。所以究竟是哪个？谁先开始在那儿工作的？吉姆还是潘？拉蒂玛尼亚和乔尔·胡伯在推特上就这个连续性错误进行了很长时间的交流。很多人写信来谈论这件事。
This is a thing. Sometimes we have things, right? The thing is, who started working there first? Bless you. Sorry. That's why you wheeled away from the microphone. Did I get far enough away from it? No.
这就是这么回事。有时我们会遇到这种情况，对吧？问题是，谁先开始在那儿工作的？保重。抱歉。这就是为什么你把椅子滑离麦克风。我离得够远了吗？没有。
Did you get far enough away? You'd have to leave the room to be far enough away from it. I leaned back and I put, I did like the sneeze in my armpit thing. If you move away from it, it doesn't make the sound cease to exist. It just makes it not like blow out your eardrums. Okay, fine. Did I not blow out your eardrums? You didn't blow out your eardrums.
你离得够远了吗？你得离开这个房间才算离得够远。我往后靠，然后我做了，我做了那个对着胳肢窝打喷嚏的动作。如果你从它旁边挪开，并不会让声音凭空消失。只会让它不至于震破你的耳膜。好吧，好吧。我没震破你的耳膜吧？你没震破你的耳膜。
Thank you. You succeeded there. Continue about this heated Twitter conversation. I will. The answer is, I don't know. Oh. Boy, my sneeze interrupted this thing. I was feeling really bad.
谢谢你。你成功了。继续讲这个激烈的推特对话。我会的。答案是，我不知道。哦。天哪，我的喷嚏打断了这个。我当时感觉真的很糟糕。
And then it's like, I checked the Bible and everything. This is just a continuity error. That's it. There's, I don't know who started there first. In one episode, we say one thing and another episode, we say another. The end. The end. That's it.
然后就像是，我查了圣经和其他所有东西。这只是一个连续性错误。就是这样。有，我不知道谁先在那儿工作的。在一集里，我们说了一件事，在另一集里，我们说了另一件事。结束。结束。就是这样。
All right. The senator had a son. We sent away and never saw again. It happens. It happens. Let's talk a little bit at 16 minutes, 45 seconds. Okay. Dwight, bus, Oscar and a male friend, Gil.
好吧。参议员有个儿子。我们把他送走，再也没有见过。这事常有。这事常有。让我们聊聊16分钟45秒。好吧。德怀特、巴士、奥斯卡和一个男性朋友吉尔。
Yes. They have shopping bags. They have ice skates. Oscar is so not sick. He's not sick. And he's like, are you going to tell Michael and Dwight at 17 minutes, 34 seconds is like, no, I won't tell Michael in exchange for a favor from you that I will ask for at some point in the future.
是的。他们拿着购物袋。他们拿着溜冰鞋。奥斯卡根本没生病。他没生病。然后他就像是，在17分钟34秒时说，你要告诉迈克尔和德怀特吗，不，我不告诉迈克尔，作为交换，你要答应我一个要求，我以后会在某个时间点提出来。
Right? Yeah. He makes this big speech. Jenna, this made me think of a TV show that my dad watched and I watched it a few times with him called Stingray. It was in the eighties and Ray would show up to help someone and he would say, I will help you in exchange for a favor that I will ask of you sometime in the future. Do you think our writers had someone who watched Stingray?
对吧？是的。他发表了长篇大论。珍娜，这让我想起了一个我爸爸看过的电视节目，我和他一起看过了好几次，叫《刺鱼》。那是八十年代的剧，雷会现身帮助某人，然后他会说，我帮你，作为交换，以后某个时间我会向你提一个要求。你觉得我们的编剧里有人看过《刺鱼》吗？
I'm 100 years old. None of you guys know what I'm talking about. I don't know where to start. You have nothing. I'm just telling you. I have so many thoughts that I don't know where to start. First of all, I'm astonished and delighted by the description of that show because it seems like Ray is going to sting you, but then help you, but then call in a favor.
我已经100岁了。你们谁也不知道我在说什么。我都不知道该从哪里开始。你什么都没有。我只是在告诉你。我有太多的想法，我都不知道从何说起。首先，我对那个节目的描述感到惊讶又高兴，因为听起来雷会刺你一下，然后帮你，但随后就会要求你还人情。
Well, I think he drives a Stingray. Oh, and his name is Ray? His name is Ray. He drives a Stingray. He drives a Stingray. There he is. Sam's pulling him up. Here's the description.
嗯，我想他开着一辆刺鱼跑车。哦，他的名字叫雷？他的名字叫雷。他开着一辆刺鱼。他开着一辆刺鱼跑车。他就在那儿。萨姆把他找出来了。这是描述。
An adventurer travels and helps people in trouble in exchange for future favors. Just like you said, it was a television series. He drove a 1965 Corvette Stingray. Uh-huh. Was his name Ray or did you add that? No. His name is Ray. The character's name is Ray.
一个冒险家四处旅行，帮助陷入困境的人，以此换取未来的恩惠。就像你说的，这是一个电视剧。他开着一辆1965年的雪佛兰科尔维特刺鱼跑车。嗯哼。他的名字叫雷，还是你加上去的？不。他的名字叫雷。这个角色的名字叫雷。
The character's name is Ray. And look, it says Ray, a man of mystery, gets people out of trouble asking for favors in return. Anyway, it might not be you guys, but it definitely made me think of that. So, you know, if you have Nickelodeon and there's Nick at night. Check out Stingray. Check out Stingray. Well, in this scene, it is also revealed not only that Oscar is not sick, but that he is gay, that Gil is his male companion, which Dwight completely misses.
这个角色的名字叫雷。你看，上面写着，雷，一个神秘的男人，把人们从麻烦中解救出来，以此换取回报。总之，可能不是你们，但它确实让我想起了那个。所以，你知道，如果你有尼克国际儿童频道，上面有深夜档。去看看《刺鱼》吧。去看看《刺鱼》吧。好吧，在这一幕中，人们还发现不仅奥斯卡没生病，而且他是同性恋，吉尔是他的男性伴侣，德怀特完全没有注意到这一点。
Completely misses. He doesn't see it. They cut to the scene of them all watching a movie together, which a lot of fans asked, is this the favor that Dwight, you think Dwight's going to call back a totally different favor? I think Oscar is so relieved when he realizes that Dwight has no idea what he's stumbled across, that he's like, do you want to hang out? Stay and hang out with us. He wants to make it a positive, like, okay, bye Dwight, take care.
完全没注意到。他根本没看出来。镜头切换到他们一起看电影的场景，很多粉丝问，你觉得这是德怀特以后要讨回的人情吗？德怀特会讨回一个完全不同的人情吗？我觉得奥斯卡意识到德怀特完全不知道自己撞破了什么秘密时，他如释重负，他就像，你想一起出去玩吗？留下来跟我们一起玩吧。他想让气氛变得积极一点，就像，好吧，拜拜德怀特，保重。
Well, you see in the background while they're watching television that Oscar reaches out and touches Gil's hand and the camera catches it. So, now the audience knows that Oscar is gay, but no one in the office does, including Dwight. We had a lot of fan questions about this. Okay. So, I reached out to Oscar and I asked him, when did you find out that your character was going to be gay? And he said he had heard, like, some rumblings from some of the writers, but he wasn't really
好吧，在他们看电视的背景里，你可以看到奥斯卡伸手去摸吉尔的手，镜头捕捉到了这一幕。所以，现在观众知道奥斯卡是同性恋，但办公室里没有任何人知道，包括德怀特。我们有很多关于这个的粉丝提问。好吧。所以我联系了奥斯卡，我问他，你是什么时候发现你的角色会是同性恋的？他说他听说过，
sure, and then Greg Daniels approached him and said, hey, Oscar, we're thinking about making your character gay. What do you think? And then Oscar said, sounds great. I love it. And then Greg said, oh good, because it's in the script. So, there you go. Back to the episode.
从一些编剧那里听到了一些风声，但他并不是很确定，然后格雷格·丹尼尔斯走近他说，嘿，奥斯卡，我们正在考虑让你的角色成为同性恋。你觉得怎么样？然后奥斯卡说，听起来太棒了。我很喜欢。然后格雷格说，哦太好了，因为剧本里已经写了。所以，就是这样。回到剧集。
Jim is in Michael's office and Michael is so gutted over revealing the secret. Now, John's performance in the scene, he is so silent and he's just, it's this mixture of compassion and disappointment. Embarrassment. He's taking it all in, but the truth is, John could not stop laughing again. I want you to be in a small confined space with Steve Carell when he does two things. When he fake laughs or fake cries. Yeah.
吉姆在迈克尔的办公室里，迈克尔因为泄露了这个秘密而痛不欲生。现在，约翰在这场戏中的表现，他是那么沉默，他只是，这是同情和失望的混合体。尴尬。他全盘接受了这一切，但事实是，约翰又一次忍不住大笑了。我希望你能和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在一个狭小的密闭空间里，当他做这两件事时。当他假笑或假哭的时候。是的。
Because when he fake cries and he's like, it is impossible not to laugh. John could not handle it. He could not handle it. And then, did you notice when Jim comes over and then Michael kind of like hugs his crotch? I wrote awkward crotch hug. Awkward crotch hug. Should we start tracking those? No.
因为当他假哭，然后他就像，根本不可能不笑。约翰招架不住。他实在招架不住。然后，你注意到当吉姆走过来时，迈克尔有点像抱住了自己的裆部吗？我写了尴尬的裆部拥抱。尴尬的裆部拥抱。我们应该开始记录这些吗？不。
All right. So, then we have the scene in the kitchen, right? Where Jim has to confront Pam because it's going around. Well, he wants her to hear it from him and not someone else. Yeah. So, Jim tells Pam, hey, you're probably going to hear this thing that I told Michael or whatever, but just, I want you to know that was from a long time ago. That was when you first started.
好吧。然后我们在厨房里有个场景，对吧？吉姆必须去面对潘，因为这事已经传开了。嗯，他希望潘是从他这里听到，而不是别人。是的。所以吉姆告诉潘，嘿，你可能会听到我告诉迈克尔的这件事或者别的什么，但只是，我想让你知道那是很久以前的事了。那是你刚开始的时候。
Three years ago. Three years ago. Yeah. Because at first, Pam is so happy. Yes. She's like, oh my gosh, this is amazing. This is the conversation I wanted to have on top of booze crews. Right.
三年前。三年前。是的。因为起初，潘太开心了。是的。她就像，哦天哪，这太棒了。这就是我想在游轮派对上聊的对话。对。
And then, when he is just so adamant that, well, I don't feel that way anymore, then she's sad. Well, when I leave the kitchen, most of the time, they kept the shot going all the way to me getting to my desk. The door would close and then they would do a spy shot of me sitting down at my desk. You would see me crying. They didn't keep it in, but I would leave and I would cry. And I, there are times when you're playing a character where you can't help but feel
然后，当他如此坚决地表示，好吧，我不再有那种感觉了，然后她就伤心了。好吧，当我离开厨房时，大多数时候，镜头一直跟拍到我走到办公桌前。门会关上，然后他们会拍我坐在办公桌前的偷拍镜头。你会看到我在哭。他们没有把这个剪进去，但我会离开，然后我会哭。而且，有时候当你扮演一个角色时，你情不自禁地会去感受
their feelings. And I have to say, I really felt Pam's heartbreak. I really did when we were performing the scene. It's not just that she wants Jim to admit feelings, it's that she wants him to save her. You know, she doesn't have the courage right now to save herself and she's going to get there. And I'm glad that that's how the show is written.
他们的情感。我必须说，当我们在表演这个场景时，我真的感受到了潘的心碎。我真的感受到了。这不仅仅是希望吉姆承认感情，而是她希望他来拯救她。（你知道，她现在没有勇气自救，但她会做到的。我很高兴剧本是这样写的。）
I'm glad that ultimately, Pam saves herself, but there's all of this in her in this moment right now. And it was a really intense thing to shoot and I'll always remember it. Wow. I didn't know that they did a spy shot of you. I would have loved to have seen that. Yeah. It's not in the deleted scenes, but I remember doing it because I remember that walk from
我很高兴最终潘自救了，但在此时此刻，她心里充满了这一切。这是一个非常激烈的拍摄过程，我永远都会记住它。哇。我不知道他们还拍了你的偷拍镜头。我很想看看那个。是的。它不在删减片段里，但我记得拍过，因为我记得从厨房走到我的办公桌的那段路感觉非常非常漫长而且脆弱。我确信。
the kitchen to my desk feeling very, very long and vulnerable. I'm sure. Okay. 19 minutes, 30 seconds. We are now at a scene with Michael and Pam where everything gets turned back on its head. Yes. We think, Jim is like, I've resolved it. Yeah.
好吧。19分钟30秒。我们现在来到了迈克尔和潘的场景，一切都被颠覆了。是的。我们以为，吉姆就像，我已经解决了。是的。
You've collected yourself. It's fine. He liked me. He doesn't like me anymore. Fine. And Michael's like, oh yeah, no, it was on the booze cruise. He had a crush on you and you're like, wait, did he tell you he had a crush on me on the booze cruise or did he have a crush on me on the booze cruise?
你已经恢复情绪了。没关系。他喜欢过我。他现在不喜欢我了。好吧。然后迈克尔就像，哦对，不，那是在游轮派对上。他暗恋过你，而你就像，等等，他是跟你说他在游轮派对上暗恋我，还是他在游轮派对上暗恋我？
And Michael's like, shut it. He's like, shut it. Now everyone's leaving for the day. Pam and Jim leave together. They do. They get an elevator together. Well in the elevator, you notice there are all of these glances where Jim looks at me while I'm looking forward, but then I look at Jim while he's looking forward.
然后迈克尔就像，闭嘴吧。他就像，闭嘴吧。现在大家都要下班了。潘和吉姆一起离开了。他们确实如此。他们一起坐上了电梯。嗯，在电梯里，你注意到有各种各样的眼神交流，吉姆看着我，而我目视前方，但接着我看着吉姆，而他目视前方。
It took us forever to time that out with getting in the elevator, glancing at each other. That was all intentional. The doors closing exactly when the doors close. It took a very, very long time. I'm very proud of how it turned out. Also David Calderhead wrote in and said, did you consciously lean into John in the final scene in the elevator? I didn't consciously do it.
我们花了很长时间才把进电梯、互相看一眼的时间配合好。这全都是刻意的。门正好在门关上的那一刻合上。这花了非常非常长的时间。我为它的呈现效果感到非常骄傲。大卫·卡尔德黑德也写信来说，在电梯里的最后一个场景中，你是不是有意识地向吉姆靠过去？我不是有意识地这么做的。
It just kind of happened, but that was a little dance that we had to choreograph and get just right. Well, I thought it was great and it was a great way to sort of wrap up that storyline of that episode. And then we have it 20 minutes, 16 seconds. Michael reveals that he was watching a Cinemax movie. The name of the movie is called More Secrets of a Call Girl. Yeah, not a real movie.
它就那么发生了，但那确实是一段我们需要排练并做到恰到好处的小舞蹈。好吧，我觉得这很棒，而且这也是收尾那一集故事线的一种绝妙方式。然后我们在20分钟16秒。迈克尔透露他正在看一部Cinemax电影。电影名字叫《应召女郎的更多秘密》。是的，不是真电影。
I looked it up. No, it's not. It's not a real movie. Michael says, you know, wait, what does he say? Does he say, I don't want to be shy? Can we hear that? It's at 20 minutes, 16 seconds. I was watching Cinemax last weekend, this movie, portrait of a prostitute, something.
我查过了。不，这不是。这不是真电影。迈克尔说，你知道，等等，他说什么？他说，我不想害羞吗？我们能听听那个吗？在20分钟16秒。我上周末在看Cinemax，这部电影，妓女的肖像，什么的。
Secrets of a call, More Secrets of a Call Girl, an elite character of Shila, is framed for murder, goes on the run, and winds up working at a bordello in Malibu. I don't want to live like that. I like it here. I don't want to be Shila. I like being Michael Scott. I don't want to be Shila. He doesn't want to be Shila.
应召女郎的秘密，更多应召女郎的秘密，一个叫希拉的高级角色，被诬陷谋杀，开始逃亡，最后在马里布的一家妓院工作。我不想那样生活。我喜欢这里。我不想成为希拉。我喜欢当迈克尔·斯科特。我不想成为希拉。他不想成为希拉。
I want to be Michael Scott. That's a good quote. I don't want to be Shila. Why didn't I make people shirts with that? I should have. You should have. I don't want to be Shila. All right, everybody.
我想成为迈克尔·斯科特。这句台词真好。我不想成为希拉。我为什么没做印有这话的T恤给别人？我应该做的。你应该做的。我不想成为希拉。好了，各位。
That was the secret. And we are back next week with The Carpet. There's some gross stuff on Michael's carpet, and he's going to figure out what exactly it was. See you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
这就是那个秘密。我们下周将带着《地毯》回归。迈克尔的地毯上有一些恶心的东西，他要弄清楚那到底是什么。下周见。回头见。感谢收听办公室女士。办公室女士由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听节目的无广告版本和我们的彩蛋袋花絮，请访问StitcherPremium.com。要免费试用StitcherPremium一个月，请使用代码Office。目前还没有这一集的评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。